okay so the attack on Titan manga was
published for over a decade and during
that time there's one specific panel
that's become more Infamous than
anything else as of making this video
there have been countless memes fan
animations and even a whole subreddit
with thousands of members dedicated to
this one particular scene in case you
have no idea what I'm talking about in
the final chapter of Attack on Titan
Aaron and Armin have a heartfelt
conversation about Mikasa during this
exchange Armin wonders if she'll ever be
able to move on with her life and find
her boyfriend or husband after Aaron
dies and in response to this Aaron loses
his mind and throws a tantrum inside the
paws Dimension with tears in his eyes he
tells Armin no I don't want that I want
her to think about me and no one else
for the rest of our life Mikasa finding
another man Even after I die I want her
to be hung up on me for a while 10 years
at least as you'd expect it didn't take
long for this to ironically become one
of Aaron's most memorable quotes in
particular the first line and the last
line to many people the wording here
just didn't sound like something you
would say and even Armin was surprised
by just how pathetic it was that's why
today we're about to explain the truth
about this moment specifically does it
detract from Aaron's character or was it
a perfectly reasonable thing to include
throughout this video I'll be as Fair as
I can to the two different perspectives
and at the end I'll tell you how my own
opinion has changed in the time since
the chapter was released alright so the
first place we need to start is with
isayama himself who actually spoke about
this scene during an interview last year
in that interview he said the idea
suddenly came to him as he was drawing
the Final Chapter because in his words
he's always loved whiny Aaron for that
reason this segment was him trying to
take the character back to his roots and
he even thought to himself Aaron is back
once he'd finished drawing it now
whether you love this panel or hate it I
think we can all agree that Aaron has
had a ton of emotional outbursts over
the years and so the whiny errand that
isayama is referring to isn't anything
new as an example there was the time he
couldn't work out how to use the odm
gear the time he broke down in front of
Ramsay all the time he straight up asked
Historia to kill him and you can see how
his behavior in scenes like this laid
the foundation for this oh obviously
there are differences that we'll be
talking about later but for now we need
to acknowledge that Aaron has never been
afraid of showing emotional
vulnerability bearing that in mind his
outburster Armin was not only perfectly
in line with his core character but it
was also a way for isayama to
demonstrate how repressed Aaron has been
from the moment he kissed his story his
hand and saw the future he wasn't
allowed to tell anyone what he knew or
Express his true feelings about it even
though he probably wanted to his
horrified face at the meadow ceremony
was the closest anyone got to seeing his
real emotions but for pretty much the
entire time after that he kept his
secrets to himself this extreme
isolation is something Armin
acknowledges in the Final Chapter and it
means Aaron's tantrum in parse was
actually four years worth of repressed
feelings coming to the surface during
those four tragic years he failed at
finding an alternative to the rumbling
he failed at keeping all of his friends
alive his one attempt at romance didn't
work and the founding Titan made him
kill his own mother on top of that he
knew he was destined to die no matter
what happened which would be a huge
mental burden for anyone let alone a 19
year old considering all of that his
emotions in the Final Chapter shouldn't
be as controversial as it is but what's
clear is that the timeskip distorted our
view of who he is as a character what I
mean is that when season 4 came around
we were introduced to an older version
of Aaron who was manipulative ruthless
and seemingly willing to put his friends
in danger based on his actions it was
easy to assume that Aaron had
organically turned into this person
during the four-year time skip however
now that we have all the facts we can
see that for most of the time skip he
didn't act like this it was only once
mikusu rejected him that he fully
committed to being Chad Aaron and that's
because after this rejection he felt
that his only remaining option was to do
the rambling and to do the rambling it
was practical to adopt this detached
Persona if Mika said had given him the
answer he wanted to hear then we all
know he would have ran away with her and
Chad Aaron never would have existed
because that personality was just a
necessary evil that he needed to set the
rumbling in motion it wasn't until the
last chapter that he was finally able to
drop the mask when no one else was
around except Armin and Since Aaron has
nothing more left to lose he just lets
it all out in addition there are two
other reasons why this panel isn't so
bad and the first is that isayama
clearly wanted the scene to have a
comedic element to it evidence not just
by the over-the-top pathetic dialogue
but also by this panel that happened a
second earlier humor is something that
had been almost totally missing because
of the whole Global genocide thing but
with the fighting now completely
finished this was one of the very few
chances to inject a tiny bit of Comedy
before the end the second point is that
underneath the humorous plain to see
that Aaron is suffering here which plays
into one of the main messages of the
series Attack on Titan was super Direct
in pushing the message that genocide is
wrong and so one way of looking at this
panel is that it's a form of punishment
having committed the worst act of
violence in human history it would be
wrong for the story to end with a happy
Aaron being satisfied with the way
things played out instead what we got
was a sad teenager who was scared to die
scared that his crush might forget about
him and who at least acknowledges that
what he did was wrong even if he doesn't
regret it which in the context of this
message was arguably the right thing to
draw with all that said it's time to
switch over to the reasons this panel
doesn't work and I think we need to
begin with Mikasa despite Aaron's love
for her being the main topic of his
meltdown the romance between these two
is something that was massively
underdeveloped the truth is that for 99
of the series Aaron didn't treat Mikasa
like someone he was in love with and
this is something isayama himself was
aware of in an interview he did a couple
of years before the manga ended he said
that for Aaron rather than a lover
mikas's presence is more like a mother
to him the love towards a mother is
considered valuable however at the same
time there are annoying Parts as well as
an audience we also saw for ourselves
that he mostly behaved around her the
same way he did with Armin and their
relationship mostly seemed like one
between family members I know some
people might argue that Aaron was just
too busy with his goals to focus on
romance but even if that's true if he's
in love with her then there would have
been more clues in his behavior to
indicate that was the case in reality
Jean was the one who displayed a more
solid romantic interest in Mikasa
evidenced by him complimenting her looks
getting nervous around her and and
fantasizing about their potential future
in Aaron's case he did virtually none of
that and the closest thing we got was
during the season 2 finale when there
was the chance for a kiss but when the
kiss never materialized it wasn't until
years later the era mentioned anything
remotely romantic Again by that time he
had been avoiding the subject for so
long that mikaso almost didn't know how
to react and despite being in love with
him she gave the answer that was most
likely to preserve their existing
friendship because of that these two
actually being a couple isn't something
that was ever firmly established
especially at this point in the timeline
and so when Aaron melts down about
Mikasa potentially finding another man
it just feels kind of unearned what
makes it even worse is the exact
language he uses for instance when he
says he wants her to be hung up on him
for 10 years at least one thing we need
to understand about all his previous
outbursts is that regardless of the
situation Aaron never stops sounding
like himself like the words he was
saying still sounded right coming from
his mouth with chapter 139 though I'm
struggling to think of a time he's ever
been this level of wine any even when he
was 10 years old I don't think it would
have been this bad as a result the
problem with this moment isn't the fact
that Aaron is having a tantrum but
rather it's the excessively pathetic
dialogue that takes things beyond the
realm of what you'd ever expect to hear
from this character the fact it also
comes at the very end of the mag it
doesn't really help since for most fans
of Aaron it leaves a bad taste in the
mouth for this to be one of the last
things we ever hear him say you could
even argue that although this moment is
meant to be comedic which sort of
justifies it being over the top the
final moments of the main character
isn't really the time to be trying to
get laughs after everything Aaron's been
through and after everything he's done
there's not really anything funny about
this situation and so it's a weird way
to send off one of the most iconic anime
characters all I'm saying is that you
could have had this exact same moment
but with the dialogue being toned down a
bit to make it more believable and less
jokey and I think if that was the case a
lot of people wouldn't have had any
problems of course you still get that
tiny one percent of fans who think that
Aaron is meant to be a Terminator who
doesn't display any real emotion but of
everyone else it would have been so much
easier to read this panel if it had the
same level of believability as his past
Outburst over the years now in terms of
my own personal opinion when the Final
Chapter came out this panel definitely
caught me by surprise in fact for any of
you who haven't seen my original review
my thinking at the time was that this
dialogue was the result of the founder
messing with his head it was easy to
think that because firstly Aaron
basically confirmed it was making him
crazy and secondly the dialogue seemed
so out of character that it felt like
the only rational explanation since then
we've all had more time to think about
it and my thoughts can pretty much be
summarized by answering these three
questions the first being whether I can
see why essayama did it to answer that
I'd say yes I can see why he would want
to do this for all the reasons that we
mentioned in the first half of the video
but if someone was to go back in time
and convince him to write the dialogue
more differently you know more in line
with the whiny errand that we knew then
I think it would have been perfectly
fine like I said before Aaron having a
meltdown is completely Justified
especially because of how repressed he
was so if it was written differently and
I think most reasonable fans wouldn't
have any issue however the reality is
that in its current form I can't say it
was a good thing for this series because
although the meaning of this panel is
clear it's unfortunately let down by the
dialogue and became an iconic moment for
all the wrong reasons that being said
let me know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below do you think
it's fine in its current form or do you
think it should have been changed or
what do you think it should have just
been removed entirely let me know down
below and if you haven't already then
sub to the channel as we are on that
long road to 500k Subs thanks for
watching as always and until the next
one peace out